Throughout my life the ten
rings gave our family power
if you wanted them to be yours one day you have
to show me you are strong enough to carry them
john you are a product of all who came before
you the legacy of your family you are your mother
and whether you like it or
not you are also your father
i told my men they wouldn't be
able to kill you if they tried
glad i was right he's just a
criminal who murders people
be careful how you speak to me boys i thought
i could change my name start a new life
but i could never escape his shadow
my son you can't run from your past
is this what you wanted
you got this thank you
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
brand new marvel Shang Chi trailer video there's
a whole bunch of big reveals here we just saw
abomination in the trailer pretty big easter egg
he's going to show up during the she-hulk series
as well so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos we're also doing a giveaway for
disney plus memberships all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and post your
favorite easter egg from the trailer on the video
probably two biggest reveals from the trailer here
is what's going on with michelle yao's character
confirming a big theory about who she's playing
and then just figuring out what's going on
with abomination during the events of this film
a lot of you are also asking if he's fighting wong
here because it looks a little bit like wang it's
another magician another person who's using magic
like doctor strange and wong use it could be him
but why would he be in a tournament fighting
against the abomination like why would he be
so hard up for cash that he would be fighting in
a tournament like this if we get any more details
about that i'll just add it to my next big Shang
Chi video but just starting at the beginning of
the footage and working our way through shot
by shot so at the beginning the mandarin whose
name is wenwu like they'll be calling him wen
wu but some people if the people who fear him
will probably call him the mandarin is talking to
Shang Chi as a child about the actual ten rings
in the history and how they've given him power
and enabled him to build this really strong family
this strong organization that is the ten rings the
way they're connecting this to the first iron man
film with the ten rings organization and obviously
in iron man 3 with the fake version the mandarin
is that he leads the true ten rings organization
and the version that we saw in iron man 1 was just
a splinter cell like there are different splinter
cells of the organization operating independently
all over the world but they're all subservient
to the true mandarin here when woo this character
that we're just meeting now tony long obviously
fantastic actor if you haven't seen any of his
kung fu or any of his action films he's also
had some really epic fights so obviously they
kind of teased that during this when he's fighting
Shang Chi for control of the 10 rings later in the
trailer you kind of see that with their different
colors of energy the very simple reason why marvel
color codes people's powers very distinctly is
so that it's easier for non-comic book readers
or casual fans to understand what's happening when
things get really crazy in the big fight scenes
with the big action scenes they just did the exact
same thing with magic during wand division so
scarlet witch's chaos magic is color-coded red in
the mcu but you also have agatha harkness's magic
which is a little bit different it's all about
stealing power from other people to power herself
up so it's color-coded purple then you have loki's
magic which is color-coded green and because
sylvie like the brand new loki variant we met
the female version of loki her magic is also
color-coded green just a slightly different shade
of green after the very first trailer dropped
a lot of people were looking at his costume
chungchi's costume and why the arms were so bare
obviously they're eventually foreshadowing him
mastering the ten rings taking them from his
father and then they'll just fill all that empty
space on his arms so in like avengers 5 when he
crosses over with the avengers or becomes part
of the team and he's using his powers he'll look
just like tony lung does in his costume only with
the orange energy the other interesting difference
between their powers too it obviously seems like
it's almost the same power just color coded a
little differently but when all the energy lights
up this giant painting here with the dragon and
the water explodes it lights up the orange color
that he's wielding later the movie will probably
explain why the mandarin's power is color-coded
purple it might be like the super soldier serum
metaphor like the whole idea that if you give the
super soldier serum to someone it just brings out
more of what's there it just amplifies more of
what you already are red skull was kind of a
monster before he got the serum and it turned him
into more of a literal monster so maybe there was
some crazy darkness inside the mandarin before he
got the 10 rings and then when he got their power
it just brought that out even more and that's why
his power is color-coded purple instead of being
color-coded orange like the orange that's lighting
up in this carving there's a couple of big battles
that are happening during the trailer some of them
in present day and some of them in the distant
past i think part of the idea is the power that
he gains from the 10 rings is what also gives him
extremely long life which is why it looks like
he hasn't gotten any older from these flashback
scenes like he basically stopped aging
the minute that he attained the 10 rings
that gets into what's going on with michelle
yao's character during the trailer i'll talk
about her in a second too because she doesn't
really show up till a little bit later it's not
super clear what's happening in this ancient
battle other than a lot of these people that
he's fighting against seem like the same order
of monks that they're fighting in present day
that she is trying to help defend like when he's
fighting his father but this brand new footage
gives you a much better tutorial for how the power
of the 10 rings works so it almost looks like he's
using them as projectiles but that's not exactly
what's happening it's almost like he's using the
rings as some sort of retractable cannon for
some special energy that they're giving off
they haven't completely explained how the
mcu-10 rings will work but in the comics
each different ring has a distinct power that's
very very different from the others at least in
all this trailer footage and the footage we've
seen so far when the mandarin uses the 10 rings
in all the different scenes it's always the same
kind of energy so they might just be simplifying
the way their power works they said one of the big
things they wanted to get across with this version
of the mandarin like the real mandarin of the
mcu was that he wasn't just a mustache twirling
villain metaphorically or literally notice that
he has no mustache in present day but also that
he was a very understandable character and you
could understand his relationship with his family
it's pretty clear that Shang Chi's mother has
died during the events of the film you finally
get a scene with her but as Shang Chi implies
even though his father leads this giant criminal
organization and just goes around hurting people
all over the world he still cares about his family
like you still understand that pretty clearly
during the film even though he's just the latest
in a long line of terrible marvel dads like
ego the living planet will you please stand up
thanos also one of marvel's most terrible dads
even hank pym has a bit of a dark past like he
has a bit of a temper on him just like comic
book hank pym so the whole idea here though is
that he eventually wants to pass his legacy on
to Shang Chi and he has to train him to be the
world's best fighter like they sort of hyped that
up during the trailer i told my fighters that they
wouldn't be able to kill you if they tried and it
seems like they definitely do try so the idea is
that even without the 10 rings he's supposed to
be someone who could fight at least most of the
avengers without crazy super powers but once he
does have the 10 rings that puts him on the level
of some of the other a-list avengers depending
on how they scale the power of the 10 rings in
the mcu he could probably go toe-to-toe with thor
for a little while thor's a little more resilient
though just his natural biology makes him almost
immune to a lot of physical attacks like he can
get thrashed by the hulk and then walk it off
most of the other avengers can't do that but you
can kind of see how they're setting him up for an
avengers arc down the road like slowly explaining
his origin story why he's such a badass fighter
and then giving him his big power upgrade with the
actual 10 rings once he defeats his father they
have a new version the marvel intro scene that's
a little bit more gold and also the flipping
pages like the comic book pages that they bake in
or also pages of Shang Chi in the comics they do
this for every new marvel project like even loki
has his own custom version of the marvel studios
intro logo so they're not totally clear what's
going on with this island here only that it's
probably connected to the great protector dragon
which seems like the movie's version of fing fang
fume like we actually see the dragon itself show
up at the end and it doesn't look anything like
comic book thing fang boom and i think the way the
main actor simulu explained it there is no actual
thing fang fume in the movie they sort of replaced
it with the idea the great protector but i think
they're implying here is that this is where the
mandarin found the ten rings and maybe michelle
yao is actually playing the dragon character and
maybe when you see them talking during the trailer
she's just taken human form like it's pretty clear
that she's training him to fight training him to
control the power of the ten rings in his eventual
battle with his father like when you see him using
that orange energy but you also see flashbacks
with the mandarin fighting against her too so it
sounds like that's also the way that he learned
to control the ten rings and that'll just be the
change that they make to his backstory from the
comics in the comics the mcluhans actually crash
a spaceship into china and the mountains in the
mandarin just happens upon it and finds the ten
rings in their spaceship and just takes them so
i don't know they're still going to be doing the
mcluhan's as space dragons but if that's the case
then this would be the place where their spaceship
would have crashed but i don't know if they're
going to be doing the spaceship from the comics
they might have some other way of explaining how
the ten rings themselves wound up on planet earth
here's the other thing too when they show you
these flashbacks of his mother sort of training
him you see all these carvings behind him it's the
same carvings that you see him standing here when
all the water explodes when he's standing with his
father all these carvings seem like they're meant
to depict this place this island that he goes to
and the dragon itself the great protector dragon
so it's sort of like this picture across the wall
depicts the history of their family in all these
other scenes too the person you see standing next
to his father is death dealer in the flashbacks
and in present day who's sort of like his chief
lieutenant i believe the tournament fight scenes
we're seeing here in all the other fight scenes
that you see happening in this giant building this
big kung fu action set piece is supposed to be
happening in the hong kong area but the whole idea
with the tournament arc that they're doing during
the movie is them kind of doing bruce lee's enter
the dragon with a lot of marvel energy because
back during the 1970s the Shang Chi character
was basically created to be their version of
bruce lee because it was part of this big kung fu
pop culture craze marvel's like we gotta get in on
that we need our version of bruce lee so that's
why they created Shang Chi bruce lee's nickname
was the dragon so it's sort of like marvel's enter
the dragon only you actually have a real dragon
in the movie as this great protector character
but enter the dragon was a tournament arc movie
it seems like he fights a couple characters before
he works his way up to the abomination like you
see him fighting his sister zealing who supposedly
he hasn't seen for about 10 years when the events
of the movie pick up it's not really clear when
this action set piece with the bus is happening
in san francisco but it's basically a giant chase
scene that goes all across san francisco with
razer fist in the other mandarin's men chasing
him down with katie because this is the same
area where the events of the ant-man movies like
ant-man and the wasp quantomania take place or
will take place in ant-man 3 i'm really curious to
see if any of those characters like even if luis
shows up during the film i know we're all kind
of hoping for jimmy woo to become like the new
phil coulson of the mcu and just show up in every
person's film and just get a little bit better at
close-up magic every new time that he shows up i
also love the twist on food dogs they have here
like they actually come to life so these are like
stone lions that are supposed to metaphorically
be guardians of chinese temples but obviously
because this is a comic book movie it's more of
a literal thing like literal stone lions that come
to life and then just start chasing everyone down
so there's still so many big questions about
what's happening during the events of the film
like why is it that the mandarin is fighting this
order of monks in the past and in present day
like what is it that he wants and what is their
family's connection to this dragon and is the
great protector dragon the only dragon because in
some of those other fight scenes in present day it
seems like they're a bunch of tiny little dragons
flying around too like i said i think that's just
going to be the mcu twist on the mcluhan's so
we'll see how they explain them being on planet
earth like where they came from if they came in an
actual spaceship like the comics or if they came
through a portal or some magical means or if they
cross through the multiverse it does seem like
this fight scene though where they're sort of
fighting each other for control of the rings is
happening in that island mountain where he went
to train with michelle yao's character i'm also
just real jacked up to see what's going on with
the abomination i'm guessing that he's not a huge
part of the movie like he's just like a special
moment during this big tournament fight scene
and whatever's been happening since the event of
avengers end game for a lot of these characters
he's just been hiding out in the criminal
underworld abroad but like i mentioned earlier
he is supposed to be a main character during the
she-hulk series those episodes are going to drop
i believe sometime in january or early next year
so i'm guessing whatever's happening with him in
the Shang Chi movie will be connected to what's
happening with him during the she-hulk series
they're also doing mark ruffalo's bruce banner
hulk during that for a number of different
reasons but i think they're also trying to hype up
some sort of rematch between hulk and abomination
but if you spotted any of the big easter eggs in
the trailer that i didn't mention in the video
just write them below in the comments and there'll
be a bunch more footage coming in the next couple
of months because we are getting closer to the
film coming out it will be a theatrical release
too it won't be coming to disney plus like they're
doing with the black widow film my black widow
movie review video we'll probably post sometime
next week i think i'm allowed to post that tuesday
i'm working on a new loki video that should post
tomorrow so if you have any special requests just
leave them in the comments below and i'll name a
giveaway winner when i post that new loki video
everyone click here for my full loki episode
3 video and click here for that other Shang
Chi trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!